hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for
anime uproar and today i will be
explaining the extremely important
four year time skip in attack on titan
and i will break down how the world of
attack on titan has changed
in that time if you are an anime only
and you need some more clarification
about what exactly is going on
in the final season of the anime or if
you're a manga reader who just needs a
refresher as you go into the final
season
then this video is for you if you
enjoyed the attack on titan content
on this channel and you want us to keep
it going please leave a like
and comment it really does help and if
you're new to anime
pro or maybe you just haven't subscribed
yet make this the video do you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all notifications
we are going to be dropping a lot more
attack on titan content in the future so
you really want to get notified when
those videos
actually drop you can also hit me up on
twitter and
instagram at anime uproar heads up
this video will provide context for what
the world of attack on titan looks like
at the beginning of the final season of
the anime i will not be spoiling major
events in the story
but depending on how far you are in the
anime at the time of watching this video
you may get some information that is yet
to be revealed in the story
so if you are super sensitive to
spoilers you have been warned
with that said though this is all
information about the world itself and
the geopolitical circumstances of that
world at the time of the time skip
i will not be revealing information
about events that are yet to occur
in the future also this video will focus
on the current global situation
beyond the walls because that is where
the plot of the story is focused at the
beginning of the final anime season
if you want me to make a second video
talking about everything that happened
within the walls during the time skip
then leave a like on this video and if
we can get 15 000 likes i
will make that second video as well now
at the beginning of the final anime
season the powerful nation of marley
the nation where aaron's father grisha
was born is currently at war with a
rival power
called the mid-east alliance marlei
is a military dictatorship that has been
fighting for dominance of the vast
continent
upon which it is located and this
current war that marlei is engaged in
against the mideast alliance has been
raging for four
years the marlians generally hate and
oppress
the ldn people as we saw in the previous
season the ldns live inside internment
zones like liberio
the place where grisha grew up and they
are denied even
basic human rights and freedoms they are
also labeled as the spawn of the devils
because of their unique ability to
transform into titans
this name comes from the marlayan belief
that aldians gained the power to
transform into titans after their
ancestor emir fritz made a deal
with a devil ironically though even
though the marlins hate and oppress
their ldn minority the very fact that
marlei has an ldn minority
is the very thing that has given this
nation a military advantage
over all other nations for the past 100
years
the first episode of the final season of
the anime does a great job of
demonstrating how the marlene military
has incorporated
titans into their combat strategy the
marland military
combines modern weapons like guns and
cannons with titan powers
in order to assert their dominance over
rival nations
these rival nations do not have a native
aldian population
and so these other nations do not have
access to titan powers
but marlei does have access to aldians
and they use both
mindless titans and titan shifters in
their military operations
in that first episode of the final
season we witnessed the marlene assault
on
fort slava which is the last remaining
stronghold of the mideast alliance
after four long years of conflict during
this assault we can see how the marlene
army uses ldn soldiers in various
different ways some aldians are used as
basically cannon fodder
some are used as mindless titans and
those elite
aldian recruits who are part of the
warrior unit are trained to use the
various
titan shifter powers but what is the
warrior unit
the most promising ldn recruits inside
the marlin military
are selected at a very young age to
become warrior candidates
they are then extensively trained and
tested until a very small number
the very best of the best are eventually
selected to inherit
one of the titan shifter powers and as
we know because of the curse of emir
someone new
has to inherit a titan shifter power
every 13 years
so new recruits are needed now potential
warrior unit candidates are extensively
brainwashed with marlene propaganda
from a very young age they are raised to
believe that their ancestors were evil
monsters and spawn of the devil who did
terrible things to all other nations
they are also
raised to believe that all the aldeans
on the island of paradise
are pure evil and that it is every
warrior's duty to sacrifice their own
life
for marlei the warrior recruits are told
that sacrificing their life for marlei
is the only way for them to make up for
the sins of their fellow
aliens they are taught that showing
undying loyalty to marlei
is the only way to prove that not all
aldians are bad and evil monsters
some warrior recruits like annie saw
through this propaganda right away
but others like reiner and gabby bought
it wholeheartedly
on top of the blatant propaganda though
warrior recruits are also incentivized
to sacrifice their lives for marlei
with the promise of honorary marlayan
citizenship
honorary marlin citizenship is a special
status that is awarded to members of the
warrior unit
and their families and this status
allows them to avoid the constant
persecution and discrimination that all
the other
aldians face in marley in theory
this status is supposed to make them
something close to equal to the other
citizens of marley but it is highly
questionable whether an
ldn can ever truly be considered free
and equal in marleian society
the hatred of the marlenes for the
aldians runs very deep
and while some warrior recruits believe
that marland's citizenship
is a great honor others believe that
honorary marlin citizenship
is just a farce now the other titan
shifter that appears during the attack
on fort slava
the one with the crazy teeth and jaw is
the new
jaw titan this is the same titan shifter
power that was formerly controlled by
emir from the 104th training corps
but this power is now being controlled
by warrior unit member
porco galliard porco is actually the
younger brother of marcel galliard
and marcel is the boy who would control
the jaw titan initially before he was
eaten by emir's mindless titan on the
island of paradise some nine years
earlier but okay let's talk about the
war between marlei
and the mideast alliance and what
started it in the first place
basically marlei has been using their
titan powers and titan shifter powers in
particular
to dominate rival nations for nearly a
century however
once word got out that marlene not only
failed to capture the founding titan on
parodies but that they also managed to
lose control of the female
titan and the colossal titan the mid
east alliance decided this was the
perfect time to attack
that is how important titan shifter
powers have become
in global geopolitics the fact that
marlei
lost two of the titan shifters
emboldened their enemies to attack them
and as a result a bloody four-year war
erupted on the continent
luckily for marley they did ultimately
manage to win this war
as a result of their successful attack
on fort slava
but even though they technically came
out of this war as winners
marley still has a major problem they
have been relying
far too much on the power of the titans
because that is what made them the
dominant military power in the world for
many decades
but while marlei has been relying on
titans the other nations were titanless
the fact that they didn't have titans of
their own to fight against marley's
titans
forced these other nations to come up
with new ways to oppose the titans
so while marlei focused on using titans
in battle
their enemies focused on creating new
and more powerful weapons technology
weapons that are strong enough to defeat
even the titans
as we saw during the battle of fort
slava the mideast alliance did have
modern weapons that were powerful enough
to take down
titans they invented artillery rounds
that could pierce
even the armored titan's body and so
reiner and the other titan shifters had
a few very close calls
with the artillery during the battle of
fort slava
yes the titans won in the end and
therefore marley won the war
but the rest of the world has come to
realize that titan powers are no longer
invincible media all over the world are
reporting that the mideast alliance was
able to seriously threaten the dominance
of the titans with their advanced
modern weapons and as modern technology
continues to improve at a rapid rate
it is clear that titan powers alone are
no longer going to be good enough to
preserve
marley's position as the world's
strongest power
marlene military officials are fully
aware of this
fact even though they just won a war
they feel like their nation
is in imminent danger their reliance on
titans has put the nation of marley
behind other nations when it comes to
modern weapons technology
and this is a massive problem if weapons
technology continues to advance at such
a fast pace
and if airplane and airship technology
in particular continues to advance so
rapidly
then titan powers will soon become
useless i mean if marley's enemies can
just use airships and airplanes to dump
a bunch of massive bombs
right on top of their titans then the
titans will get blown to bits and they
will be useless
and so the marlene military is now in a
serious predicament
they still have the strongest military
in the world for the time being because
of their titan
powers but they know that this state of
affairs is fleeting
in the very near future their rivals
will inevitably defeat them
with their superior technology unless
marlene makes drastic changes soon
its destruction is inevitable after some
prompting from zeke yeager the marlene
military decides that they should once
again
attack paradise island they need to
finally get their hands on the founding
titan power
and they need to recover the female and
colossal titan if they can do this
then they can remain the dominant
military power for long enough to catch
up to the rest of the world
technologically and so after four years
the island of paradise is once again a
target for the marlene military
and for zeke jaeger and the marland
warriors in particular
but it won't be so easy this time around
the aldeans and paradise now have the
colossal titan power
along with aaron's attack titan and in
fact during the course of the time skip
marley sent 32 scouting ships to
paradise island
and none of those ships ever returned
the islanders are clearly serious about
defending the island and protecting
themselves and they are fully aware that
enemies across the ocean are targeting
them so
infiltrating parodies won't be so easy
this time around
it certainly won't be like last time
when most of the islanders didn't even
know that the outside world existed
but beyond marlene military interests
the current geopolitical situation in
the world of attack on titan could bring
about the
end of the entire alden race as we know
the ldn people are despised by marlenes
but the aldians are allowed to continue
living in marley because the country's
military still relies on titan powers
and only aldians can become titans
but because marlands have been using ldn
titans to subjugate
other nations for nearly 100 years those
other nations also hate aldians and see
them as dangerous
monsters so what do you think will
happen to the aldians
once titan powers are no longer an
important factor
in modern warfare the sad truth is that
once titan powers become
irrelevant on the battlefield the ldn
people will become disposable
everyone hates and fears them because of
their ability to turn into titans
and when they are no longer needed their
future will be
very bleak no one has any sympathy for
them
in marlei or in the other nations and
when we get to the point that no one
relies on the aldians and their titan
shifter powers anymore it is highly
likely that they will be completely
exterminated they are not viewed as
human beings by the marlenes and the
other global powers
they are viewed as monsters and devils
and so when they are no longer needed
for anything
they will likely be disposed of that is
the
ugly truth that every elder in marle who
is aware of the current geopolitical
situation has to grapple with including
zeke
reiner and all the others and that is
where we are
at this point in the story one big war
has just ended
but another one could erupt at any
moment modern weapons technology
is quickly surpassing the power of the
titans and that could mean big trouble
for the nation of marley
and for every single aldian living in
marley and of course the island of
paradise
is once again in the crosshairs of the
marlene military but
this time the marlans are going to be
facing a very different type of opponent
on the island if you enjoyed this video
definitely leave a like and comment to
let me know
and if you want to see me make a part 2
where i explain everything that happened
on the island of parodies itself during
the time skip
then make sure that we get this video to
15 000 likes and i will make that second
video for you guys
as well don't forget to subscribe to
anime uproar and hit that notification
bell to turn on
all notifications and you can also hit
me up on twitter
and instagram at animeopror
i want to give a big thank you to all of
our anime approach patrons for making
videos like this one possible
special thank you to alpha sigma
disciple
of lord twigo himself and i can't forget
all of our
the one tier patrons the ones who rise
above
all other clans including ingrata
the world acquired respect liam thompson
pate heffer
ruthean yx emperor otaku thomas jones
spidey life denial
big buddhist tungsten tarkis and denki
kaminari and finally thank you to all of
our pro hero tier patrons including the
one and only gilgamesh
steelers angel cruz anatoly kazatsky
cricket xp
joe stanton very gucci jessica calafan
alicia octor
bonnie parks hinokami and water their
red-haired raven
florian joy and garcia jack watches
anime fat boy
games deadly saint matthew cruz and
anthony schreiber
if you enjoy our videos and you feel
that they provide value for you consider
supporting us
on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patron exclusive
discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these
legendary people as always thank you
guys so much for watching and until next
time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you